welcome everyone to the second day of
the bootcamp um
very happy that because this will
continue today uh this tutorial from
yesterday so yesterday because costas
gave
uh an intro to the
landscape of uh equilibrium computation
in
uh convex concave non-convex concave
games and generally games that arise in
machine learning
and then in his second part
he
dive deeper into
situations where things are easy meaning
that things are tractable so convection
cave games and also correlated in course
correlated equilibrium general games
and today we're he's going to cover the
harder topics so he's going to go into
non-concave games
uh the complexity of computing
equilibrium local solutions in these
situations
and potential ways that we can go around
this interactability think again alright
thank you very much uh hi everybody good
morning
so i will uh indeed move to uh more more
complex uh scenarios today
and uh just to remind you uh
you know the plan of this tutorial
so yesterday i covered situations where
you have a strategic setting where
the utility of every agent is concave
in their own actions
i talked about uh
learning dynamics how to remove
oscillations and how to uh
get fast convergence rates to
equilibrium
uh today i'm gonna switch attention to
uh right so so those games are motivated
by classical applications uh
of game theory
today i'm gonna move to a different
setting motivated by more recent
applications
of game theory in machine learning
they consider non-concave games these
are games where
uh agents utilities are not necessarily
concave in their own actions
also which is the same as saying that
their loss functions are non-convex in
their own actions right
and
i want to understand what types of
equilibria
are guaranteed to exist in this setting
and how complex it is to find them
all right
expression
the slides are here yeah okay it's
different from yesterday
um
good so in part three i'm gonna dive
into what types of solution concepts
exist in the setting
um
long story short
even local notions are going to be
intractable
and i'll explain why that happens
and in part four which is in the next
hour i'm gonna
look at how to go around the
interact-ability barrier
by
thinking about special game classes that
are broad enough to capture interesting
uh and important applications
but narrow enough that
the interactability can be sidestepped
all right so starting with this part of
the tutorial
as i was saying yesterday many recent
applications in machine learning involve
multi-agent learning
and from a game theoretic standpoint
uh the types of applications you see
here on the board
and you know you know extrapolating to
the future
the types of applications that i expect
to see
are coming in the next decade
you have a multi-agent
problem
agents
are supposed to choose high dimensional
continuous
actions
and what makes it a strategic scenario
not a distributed optimization scenario
is that every agent has their own
utility function that they wish to
optimize
except they don't control all the inputs
to that function they control one of the
inputs and the other inputs depend on
the other guys
alright that could be as i was saying
yesterday i might be thinking of
utilities that i
want to maximize
or losses that we want to minimize you
know this is minus that so
i think today i will be consistently
using the utility
and notation and not the loss notation
but i'm reminding
you of that alternative view in case
that connects better yesterday okay
now
the types of applications i had on the
previous board
as i was saying uh yesterday
and i repeated they involve situations
where
uh
yeah so the
decision is high dimensional and
continuous
uh uh agents may actually even impose
constraints of what actions are
available to others so i will generally
be represented representing the
constraint set of the actions as
calligraphic s
uh i'm gonna assume it's compact and
convex
and uh
right so
they wanna maximize utilities that
depend on their own action and the
actions of the others
that are non-concave in their own
actions
typically
which is a miles minus the plus is that
uh typically their lips it's
differentiable and smooth at least
almost everywhere
and
you know another bonus is that these
utility functions are not really known
they really
are known uh
you know only first order information is
known about them but i mean you know you
can dive deeper and you know
uh you know uh
get hired or their info but it's
expensive okay so we can think of it as
you know we can think of it as having
access to first order information if you
you know try harder maybe second order
and so forth
i'm gonna be calling these types of
games
smooth
non-concave
continuous games okay so they're
non-concave because the utilities are
not concave in one on one's own actions
uh they're smooth because the utilities
are at least smooth
uh they're continuous because the
decisions are uh
you know continues uh
and yeah they're typically high
dimensional as well
uh so just a remark for you know those
more familiar with the game theoretic
setting of normal form games
the setting that i have here is
certainly rich enough to capture the
standard normal form setting right where
you have
every agent has a finite number of
strategies and they want to and they
want to choose a randomization over
those
but certainly this setting certainly
captures that because you can always set
your
action set
to be the simplex over your
[Music]
actions the finite set of actions that
you have
and have a utility function that depends
on everybody's randomizations and it's
just the expected uh utility of the
action profile chosen under the product
measure of these mixed strategies so
certainly okay
my setting is you know much richer than
the standard setting
and it's much harder because this is a
multi-linear function in the end but you
know i'm talking about non-concave
settings here
the other day marker i want to
[Music]
yeah you well
can you say a word about uh
the last
line there uh this one here no well what
why
about that
the last line before the yeah this one
why is this the only access we have to
so i remember that uh if you you know
if uh your actions are parameters of a
neural net and these are plugged into
some nativity and you know other
people's actions come into play
you know i said earlier that
you know
it's typically easy to get this type of
info and if you spend a lot more money
[Music]
all right so that starts
this remarkable was you know
uh clear
and the last thing i want to remark
another trivial point is that with
non-concavity equilibrium may not exist
why because you can take games like this
one
you have two agents
they're playing a zero-sum game
the
utility of one player is the difference
squared
the utility of the other player is minus
that
and this game has no equilibrium why
because
you know
uh
whatever you know fx1 and x2 are
different
uh u2 wants to uh what was to tighten it
was to come close wants to go on x1
but if x2 is on x1 x1 wants to go as far
as way as possible
so there's no equilibrium here yeah
makes sense
cool so this yeah a question there's a
question from another
internet is that a promise reduction
how do we refute fake utilities or fake
gradients
which reduction
actually i didn't talk about any
reduction
it is
a model of a game right uh i mean uh
you know how do you refute that
potentially tensorflow may turn their
own gradients to you
i guess you have to trust tensorflow
that you know tensorflow returns there
are gradients
so let me just make that remark and
leave it at that
right so yeah so you create you know you
write down your model everybody runs on
their model there's some utilities
neural nets come into play
and you have access to tensorflow and
they return the gradients okay this is
my model
uh
there's no stochasticity in place here
right i mean
[Music]
uh
[Music]
where
um you know the utilities involve an
expectation
and really have access only to expect it
to to to stochastic rate so that's
that's inspiration was more like you
know
later on for later okay so let's save
that for later
i'm not there yet
okay good
so here's a
here's a uh
overarching question
this here are some overarching questions
i want to ask for this settings again
you know like this setting
captures the classical setting for which
we have
a many solution concept but this is a
different beast like oliver don't exist
necessarily so the questions i want to
ask is
what are the game theoretic
recommendations for this kind of
settings what are meaningful solution
concepts that we as analysts of these
games
uh want to suggest
uh are reasonable
operating points for these types of
games
and also if we answer that are they
practically attainable
now
what do i mean by meaningful
at the very least there must always
exist there shouldn't be any question
about their existence because you know
if i you know if
if our axiom is you know non-concave
games uh
uh should be analyzed at this type of
equilibrium then it better be that this
equilibrium you know has guaranteed
existence if if uh its existence is uh
in question
then uh
uh you know uh our theories sometimes
work and sometimes doesn't work right so
newton wouldn't be as famous if his
theory partially worked
um
all right so that should at least be
universal
uh there should also be i mean if this
is a model of you know
uh you know of how agents uh
uh behave in a situation like that
uh whatever solution concept
we know we propose as an axiom of you
know what rational behavior might be
should better be verifiable with
information that agents have
about their utilities right so if
they have first-order access to their
utilities whatever we propose should be
verifiable with that information right
you shouldn't ask them to solve an empty
heart problem to decide if they're happy
with the situation in hand
um
so on the practical attainable front
well
you know
what we'd like is
that they are efficiently reachable with
the you know
information that the agents have about
their utilities as well
through graded descent or some similar
lightweight uh optimization
so these are the this is the rata for
uh a solution concept if i were to
postulate one
and uh you know axiomatize that
agents in the situation like that behave
in this way
and i have a proposal for you
here it is
um uh so i'm gonna say that a strategy
profile x-star which contains a strategy
for each of my agents here
and satisfies the constraints
of my problem
uh is a first order
local nash equilibrium
if for every agent
if if that agent asks themselves
you know hey i have first order
information about my my utility you know
could i improve my utility by just doing
a graded step
subject to the constraints and the
problem so
uh imagine the agent says okay let me
fix what the other guys are doing
compute the gradient of my utility where
i uh
where i currently play with respect to
my variables
try to move in that direction okay maybe
there is some meter here if you want
from the current point some meter in
this direction
and then project back to the constraints
as
those are whatever concerns are imposed
by the other people
which is this symbol here
this is the constraints for person i
given the strategies of the others if
that whole mental exercise
brings me back to what i'm currently
playing
i'm like you know
[Music]
with the information that i have
that's reasonable
okay this is my uh proposed uh
local
nash equilibrium concept
so sorry about
questions not at all but yeah
normally a solution concept tries to
capture
uh behavior of the players
who are the players here and why do you
assume that
these are the kinds of moves they will
find
some in the track setting so my players
are these two guys
these are my players
[Laughter]
i want one to
encounter one of them
but i'm asking seriously i mean
what kinds of situations yeah
um
are these
neural networks playing against each
other or
so uh
but
like uh think of it as follows right so
imagine that you have uh you want to
build your robot that you're gonna
launch in the wild
and um
you know that the robot will go like
this yeah it looks like this right
so that robot has uh some parameters
that you can uh
uh
you know and
download its operation in the world
now this robot is going to encounter you
know other robots
and uh
you know their decisions are going to be
entangled
and that robot doesn't really understand
the world so much doesn't really
understand so but it can take grading
you know you can compute the gradient of
its own utility of its own actions so
that is the situation
so you're assuming there's some computer
system that is running something and
what it can do is to compute gradients
yes and that's why
that's right that's exactly right and
you know i know about the well i guess
my my solution is like you know these
robots in the world interacting on the
robots and it's like okay let me try to
improve my situation
i do great in steps i do find great
instruction research doesn't it doesn't
work okay let me stay here this is the
solution
how does this first order
nash equilibrium concept compared to
the one in which you have you assume
there's nothing within a bowl that would
change your current strategy
yeah that's a great question okay so
save it for
face life or
[Music]
linear my gradient deformation is you
know captures everything i can do right
in fact like
you know like based on the other
people's actions either it's flat so i'm
happy
or it uh is tilted it's a line so my
activity is a line if you fix everyone
else
my utility is linear in my own stuff
so if it's tilted then i can move
somewhere if it's flat i'm like okay
so it's a nash in the normal form
setting
but it generalizes that to the
non-complete setting so let me actually
these two pictures maybe like clarifying
that situation
so
uh from players from player artist
viewpoint
uh
they're happy
if either of these two occurs
uh either
so this is the constraints imposed to
this player by what the other guys are
doing at x-star
uh it's a subset of you know the action
space of h and i
so either agent eyes on the boundary of
uh the constraints
and if they were to do a grading step
that would land them outside and project
back to this point like it's orthogonal
to the boundary at this point
or what they're playing is inside and
the gradient is zero
these are the two acceptable scenarios
for these two you know from from player
i's
viewpoint these are the local optimality
conditions
for player i
and you know this is my robot here and
it's thinking
uh xi star
is the best response to what the other
robots are doing
as far as the first order taylor
approximation to my utility
is concerned
okay so this is the suggestion
excuse me you really need
convexity of this set on this
uh optimization problems
so in that scenario you only need second
order
local
that's why i said it's a first order
local national policy
right
and as you know uh
to check if something is a local minimum
it's an empty hard problem
because you you know maybe second order
info isn't ignored so you have to do the
third order fourth order
who knows what it's going to so i don't
want to get there because if you're
going to lose existence and it's not a
hard problem just to check
even for a single agent optimization
checking if something's a local mean is
an epic problem so i don't want to start
already in a situation where
the agents cannot verify anything even
if everybody themselves right so i mean
that's why i have very sorry
but that's a great one
[Music]
good
okay so this is the definition of the
local mesh
and what do we have here so this is just
a summary slide i'm just summarizing all
the info i had before
so proposition number one
is this thing is guaranteed to exist as
long as as i mean pointed out the set is
convex and compact
if your
constraint set constraining all actions
is convex and compact
then such a thing is guaranteed to exist
no matter what your utilities are
impression
you can have so you can define it in the
step size if you want it's all coming
out there
right because you know think of this
picture
well if uh if this step uh started if
you know if a step size of one satisfies
this step size of it will satisfy this
and similarly that doesn't matter
substance is not um
which is good because you don't know
what step size everybody's using
uh so uh okay so this notion is both
verifiable with the information that the
admin has
bring it to you uh and yeah that's it
yes
let's get let's get to it yeah yeah
nope not really but
uh
it would be relevant or maybe let's see
it would be relevant in this picture
yeah
like uh
uh you know yorita will will determine a
little bit how much room there is i mean
you know if you make you know huge steps
you will be unhappy if you but yeah
[Music]
all right so
i'm coming back to your question
uh
your question uh about how does this
compare to what i was talking about
yesterday
which was jiggling things and not
changing them so yesterday i talked
about uh
uh
single agent optimization and i defined
the notion of epsilon delta local
maximum so i was talking about minima
but now
to
maximize confusion of swiss utilities
right so
uh
so
local
a point x is a local maximum if
x star if you cannot jiggle x star
in a ball
delta around it
to increase the function by more than
epsilon right so if you were to move to
x
you wouldn't get more than this plus
epsilon if you take that to the other
side that's a notion of epsilon delta
local maximum i was talking about
yesterday
i similarly defined this other concept
for two player zero sum
games
calling a point x star y star and
epsilon delta local min max equilibrium
if
the uh x player
cannot jiggle x in a bolt around
xr
to decrease his
utility
to uh
yeah so okay so this guy's trying to
minimize to decrease the utility of the
other player by more than epsilon
and similarly why cannot jiggle you know
why star
to increase his utility more than that
so that's what i was talking about
yesterday let's try to generalize that
for multi-agent games
so here's a multi-agent game
constraints
people trying to maximize their own
utilities but they depend on the other
people so what is an epsilon delta by
the same token epsilon delta local nash
equilibrium it's a point x star such
that
for every player
they cannot jiggle their x i star to
some other x i to increase their utility
by more than epsilon
right jiggle within a ball of red is
delta
so this is the by the same token
right so you know like this
led to this was you know by the same
token leads to this now how does this
compare
to the concept of
uh local nash equilibrium i was talking
about earlier
were they the same okay so uh uh you
know if you consider approximation so uh
so so
this is the approximate version of the
notion i was talking about before
an agent
uh cannot
will not be changing their point by more
than gamma if they do a graded step this
is what this says
rather than exact equality here it's an
approximate version like
yeah i could uh you know i could change
but it just changed a little bit okay
this is what it says
so
in the regime where
delta
here delta here
is smaller than
you know root 2 epsilon here
over l the the smoothness of the
utilities involved here
these are two computational equivalents
right so in other words if you want to
compute such a point
you can set your gamma appropriately
find such a point and this will be at
this point similarly if you're
interested in a particular gamma
you can set your epsilon delta
over here find such a point and get your
approximate so these are a computational
equivalent the problems these are
you know two faces of the same coin
and in particular
this implies that this thing exists
in this regime because i just argued
that this exists even with gamma equals
zero
and because the equivalence holds in
this regime
uh these things exist as long as you are
not too greedy about the radius in which
you're trying to find deviations
yes
yeah
so
for any uh yeah for any exactly so
if you are in this regime
and you are you are asking for an
epsilon delta local nash in this sense
there is a gamma that depends on epsilon
and lambda
such that if you find uh such a fixed
point
this will automatically be
uh satisfying these constraints as well
and also the other direction if you
are interested in a particular gamma
there is a way to set epsilon delta here
so that if you find a point satisfying
this constraints this will automatically
also satisfy these constraints
right so these are equivalent yes
[Music]
because this function here is lifted
right this function is lips is because
it contains gradient and very smooth
sorry
utilities are smooth so the gradient is
ellipses which makes this lipsense the
whole thing is continuous so there is a
fixed one
so that's why i call it the proposition
in the area there's this kind of obvious
right so um
yeah so it's a proposition right so the
fact that this exists shouldn't be
surprising this
under smoothness of use
this is a continuous mount
right so this is continuous
the objection is continuous
projection so this is a continuous map
so by birth and i said it's converted
so
i mean okay right so you have to do
something though okay so
because i can say they're entangled the
way i've said it so you cannot just uh
this is not the right amount so you have
to
yes
so
if if the gradient is not the ellipse
right
but it's continuous yes
you see you have existence but you don't
have the equivalence correct uh
yes
so the equivalence is because you need
the graph to be ellipses to have the
equivalence right right
yes
yeah
yeah sorry i'm reading this book but i
have a question uh
so if
so if i'm in uh in a first order local
match equilibrium is there and i can't
change my action
is there a chance that i can change the
constraints i impose on other players to
improve my utility what do we assume
that constraints um perfectly
[Music]
by changing your reaction you can
influence the stuff available to other
people
but this is not gonna
uh
yeah so this but you know but but that
is kind of like a
don't look ahead it's kind of that
scenario
uh
right because you have to think about
like if i if i change
my action now potentially i'm making my
utility worse
but that will constrain the other people
to react to that so maybe that will
become better so that is not kind of it
doesn't kind of like
to look ahead solution concept uh which
i haven't thought about it's like
typically in game theory we think about
one step ahead
but uh
uh for for equilibrium notions but
that's an interesting idea to pursue
like uh yeah like if you're in a
uh if the constraints are coupling
agents actually in a funky way
of course what you just said wouldn't
work for product constraints but like if
it if the concerns are funky
maybe if i'm smart enough like eva was
saying
yesterday
uh if i think about the you know
a multi-step kind of like optimizations
and maybe you know with some patients as
i will say yesterday
uh i can uh improve myself yeah
so this is not part of this uh
nash equilibrium concept because
uh you know i'm assuming that
if the agent cannot improve
with one step they're not going to be
thinking oh you know like that will make
you know young
tnc strategy so then that will improve
me so but don't have such a good
understanding of the setting if you want
to think more patiently like this
yeah
all right so this is uh the existence
slide so
you could be thinking of it like this or
you could be thinking of it like this
whatever you guys prefer
yeah
yeah
uh what is the local equilibrium there
uh let's see uh
uh maybe zero is there
yeah because like that makes the
gradient of one of the two like well it
makes one player happy for the other
zero
yeah the gradient version works but the
other one doesn't
uh there's always you can always move x1
can always move away from x
okay so make uh one of the two happy so
why is
two one is happy one is maximizing
like what is the greater than the other
zero right the gradients support zero
but the
exponential
yeah but like
if you satisfy this constraint you're
not going to be improving over the next
one
right so so that's okay so that's why
this is important
otherwise we lose existence
right so like if you set the radius in
which you're considering deviations
would be smaller than a root
the target x over the smoothness of that
you know x one minus two squared
if you just write things out
that won't give you any problem better
than actually
right see so even though it's an exact
location in one definition it might not
be
yeah i don't know yeah i mean
sure
but either like whatever like if you
want to find such a thing you can run
this album vice versa right
uh
cool
are they practically attainable
this is the next question so these are
reasonable
and they always exist
reason number one universal verifiable
with information people have are they
practical practically attendant
so again people say no right because
uh
you know in that situation you have uh
in fact a two-player sub-game
with uh
a utility for either player that is not
something in their own actions
and what they try to do is to run
greater descent ascent
um
i mean the fixed points of the upgrading
the center sands
are the local equilibrium circular
right because you know my definition was
really a fixed point of green descent
ascent
so this is what i mean you know
without maybe uh
clarity about the solution concepts are
always existence and so forth just the
mere fact that they're running these
types of dynamics they're shooting for
this kind of solutions
and what they find is that these things
uh don't work
so how do you explain that how do we
explain that these things exist okay so
the way the way we find local national
library exists
so in principle
uh this is you know these are the fixed
points of the methods that people are
running
but uh
why are they not converging or converts
to garbage solutions as i was saying
yesterday
uh let me try to offer a computation
like the complexity uh
explanation of that phenomenon
by setting this result with a
strategic-like seminars of the turkeys
so the result says that
even in two players here sound
even in two even if you're facing you
know
a two percent not uh and player you know
nazi or something but like even if you
have a
two player zero sound
a smooth normal game like again
uh
any methods
any method not necessarily good in the
center center any method that
accesses utilities
they are validates and gradient by
liquidities
let alone what guns is stochastic access
even if you have deterministic access
uh it will need exponentially many steps
to find in the dimension of the problem
or one over gamma
the approximation
to compute even a gamma approximate
equilibrium
right so
that's an unconditional result it
doesn't become any complexity of
assumption
if you only access
the information
the first order queries
you will have to take in general
exponentially many steps to get to a
approximate
local first-order nash equilibrium
even if again used to lose your sum
so what's the claim
which you know potentially explains
a little bit the frustration in practice
the games
right you know
with all the asterisks
these are not worst case problems blah
blah blah but uh
at least what he says is that we cannot
hope to build a framework for
these types of games that is using
greater descent or a variant of that
it is guaranteed to converge to even
local approximate
sorry
that means that whenever we are liking
we have something good
means that either the dimension is small
or the error that we ask
yeah or not the utilities are special
special and the problem is not uh uh we
have extra structure for the utilities
right right
maybe the definition
maybe but that's the same okay
maybe that's not the right notion maybe
you have to find a different one
that is meaningful and universal
so but you know like to me the fact that
people are going to say the same type of
things means that this would pass
yeah um can you explain why this is like
relevant to gans of how often we could
use log bots for dance where then like
we don't even have a lipschitz loss so
it's like a
different type of curvature
uh
again if they continue some special
structure
maybe the worst case results don't hold
right
uh yeah i mean uh
i guess let me put it this way this is
an open invitation to tell me why guns
would work
or you know my part you know
and it's not just uh detection is
important right because if you really
are a guard believer
it'd be nice to understand why in under
what scenarios you know this would work
that would help our understanding of
you know
what these things do
uh okay so that was about first order
matters how about second order third
door whatever methods
uh
okay so are there
a complex genetic assumption that the
class ppd is not
equal to p
ah any method first or second order or
whatever
uh we'll have to make super polynomially
many steps to find uh a approximate
local nash equilibrium
okay so you choose your poison if you
don't want a
uh like a conditional result you can
it's just uh you can you can use the
query lower bound here
but uh
you know
under a complex theoretical result even
second order
or higher order methods will have
to take super polynomial many steps yeah
i will become technical now
what do we assume as
the the axis of the utility because for
example if the utility has locations
it seems that everyone here will be a
little bit frustrated because
needs or exponentials
would need lots of time to compute them
like in p space
like this is not for the the every query
so you say the conditional result
creating utilities takes one constant
time like i i agree but what is the
it is a real number it is a rational
number
so for this result for the conditional
result this is the previous one is a
query result right so for this result
you know you're given a subroutine
yeah so for the unconditional result
yeah how robust it is to graduate
descent so if i have any dynamics and i
want to find approximate fixed points
so anything disorder okay are you
checking the solution
utilities something like globally safety
real stuff
i don't know what you mean because this
is a great little bomb
but i can do extra gratitude right
okay that's
yeah so what when when people actually
run
stochastic gradients
do they do they converge to something
uh don't ask me
my
[Music]
[Music]
it does not generally converge like
whenever you know like cycles or
diverges or whatever yes it's chaotic as
far as i understand so i mean
uh
you know
there are a little bit this way there
are very few gun experts in the world
there are many more you know um
uh
you know minimizers but uh very few guys
so what they do is we're like
so one last comment i guess so if if you
use a dynamic and it converges
it should converge to the first order
local nas right i mean
right so
in your example where you you had this
figure
that one was a local nas right a first
order local mass with this symbols right
because it converges there so
this notion you can have like garbages
in the end right you can end up with in
garbage
but even that is computational
right so yeah so now just to be serious
question though i mean people like uh
my understanding is that many successful
gang approaches
you know
you know they start with you know like
uh they do all sorts of hacks like
uh generating a low dimensional uh
distribution first condition on that get
bigger and so forth but it is an art
form it's not certainly not
uh something that you know like uh
you know
you know after a few days with deep
learning you can actually do it it means
a lot of work
unpredictable so if i understand
correctly there's really no
reason to look for a solution concept
that will explain
uh the actual behavior
because the behavior doesn't converge
you know i i mean
i think it would be nice to come up with
other
solution concepts
together with algorithms that are
guaranteed to get there then as well as
gonna say like like
you know
or even frameworks including the the
statistical aspects of this
that uh you know you know as i was
saying like build it up and start from
low dimensional to high dimension
so that the arising problems are not as
uh interactable
yeah so i mean this is like a whole open
uh you know this is like a whole uh
kind of uh you know interesting stuff
but uh
uh the backer you know this is a
backdrop
yeah i think so there's also like a lot
of tricks that people use that seems to
improve training so they're gonna be
interesting to at least say why do those
tricks move in the right direction
um uh
or yeah
and then also to invent new tricks
yeah so
you stated this result in kind of an
awkward way is it ppid hard or is there
something hard yeah
by christopher dimitri in the 90s
and um
it was a successful class for complexity
theory in the sense that
it captures exactly the complexity of
important problems like uh it exactly
captures in the sense that these
problems are ppd complete
uh the complexity of the problem of
finding
fixed points of ellipses continuous
functions
and finding a mixed nash equilibria in
normal form games the games that i
mentioned in the very beginning where
every agent has a finite number of
actions and they randomize over them and
the utilities are multilinear
so
p-pad captures exactly the complexity of
these uh
and what we show is that computing
local nash even in two players here some
smooth non-concave games is exactly as
hard as these problems it's a ppd
completeness result to answer to grant's
uh
straightforwardly
now
okay so
i want to give some intuition about the
proof
and the question i want to ask is why
are even okay this is interesting i
guess a little bit of a pan here why are
even two players too many
okay uh okay that was a geeky one
okay so um
so i want to compare
[Music]
something we know how to solve
well
which is finding local optima in single
agent optimization problems
a problem that you know it's tractable
if you care about local optimal
solutions
uh
and a problem that i claim is hard and i
wanna understand you know like
why is it that uh single agent
non-convex minimization aka non-concave
maximization
why is it an easy problem if you care
about local solutions
well on the other hand
even just two players zero sum
non-concave games are hard why is it
such a big difference between these two
problems
uh to make this comparison i will
consider
objective improvement
objective improving
moves on the left side
and better response dynamics on the
right hand side which is the analog of
objective improvement so here's a
picture so here's what could happen
in a
non-convex minimization problem
right so you know the space in my
picture is two dimensional so the single
agent controls both dimensions
and uh here i'm tracking you know
objective improving uh path
that my agent will follow
both of these objective improving paths
satisfy
well the the objective has to go down in
every step okay so like you see the
picture like
the objective goes down you know
this is a nice case which goes down by
one point in every step but in an event
in an objective improving path that's
the definition of objective improvement
but the exactly goes down okay by
definition of objective improvement
okay so moving along such a path makes
progress towards a local minimum
and if your objective is lower bounded
and if you insist that every step you
take
is at least absolutely improving
then you can even bound the number of
steps of such steps you need to take
before you get to an epsilon
local minimum
right because
you chip away you chip away epsilon
every step
and if you're lower bounded
you know you you cannot trip away too
many epsilons until you hit the bottom
okay so
in a situation like on the left hand
side objective improving steps
make progress towards the solution
let's see what happens on the right hand
side what if people
are competing in a zero-sum game
and they each want to make improving
improvement steps
so here's what a picture what the
picture may look like so here i'm
imagining uh a two player zero sum k
again
with an objective that this player wants
to minimize and this player wants to
maximize
and i'm showing you two
possibilities okay
first of all better response
paths may be cyclic so they're not false
so this is a possible
uh uh better response path right so like
you know the objective starts at three
the minimizing player moves to the right
to decrease it
then the maximizing player takes over
increases back to three
down to one up to three and we got into
a cycle
so uh uh better response dynamics may be
cyclic they don't they're not
necessarily paths
uh so this path is wrong
uh and uh
even if
even if you have a better improving uh
if you have even if you have a better
better response path that is really a
path
another negative feature you have is
that
creating the function value on this path
doesn't give you any hints about how far
from the end of that path you are
because
you can very easily have the objective
the values of the objective function
repeating along that path
like in the case right three to one
two three two one two three right and so
so uh
uh no information gain
uh by querying you know even if i tell
you that you know like where you quit it
is on a
path and not a cycle right
you know by looking at these two you
don't know if these two is here here
here you you get not much info about
where the
uh uh
uh min max equilibria are points where
in one direction you cannot decrease in
the other direction you cannot increase
now this is intuition this is all
intuitions alternative detectability
proof
ideally what you'd like to do is to take
such a path
you want a serpentine-like path
a space-filling type of path and you
know embed that path in this ambient
space
uh you know have the values of the
objective repeat on this path
in such a way that quitting along this
path or anywhere in the ambient space
does not give you any hints or much hint
about where the local midmark solutions
are this is ideally what you'd like to
do
but but we don't know how to do that
really
i mean we know how to do it now
but we didn't know how to do this
construction uh without actually first
proving our ppt completeness result and
then exploiting some aspect of that
hardness proof to turn it into a query
lower bound so we were first able to
establish the complex theoretic result
and then
exploited the feature of that
uh hardness reduction
to turn it into a
query lower bound
okay so we couldn't implement this
strategy
uh at once we just you know you know if
you guys think about it maybe you can
right so
but uh uh we we first showed the pbd
completely not exploited an aspect of
the proof to turn it into an
unconditional result
[Music]
but it doesn't mean like it doesn't mean
that we're gonna actually follow this
path so it's like i'm just telling you
like
if you are an optimizer and you're like
okay
you're an optimizer right forget about
the players you're an opportunist you
might find a lot of mouse
you play the objective here you see it
too oh you're like oh let me look to the
left i see one to the right i see three
so isn't it reasonable to go here and
see if that maybe is a lot of nash
but then you put it down and you're like
oh it's a two
it doesn't work you can the other player
could improve so it's not stable so
maybe let me click here oops that
doesn't work because you can go here
okay let me go over here oh it's a two
over here's another two a three a one a
two i can make you query everywhere
before you see it you see useful
in the analogy at the end of the
optimizing path uh what we have what is
the
local house
[Music]
yeah for example like if this is a local
dash
then around the three you cannot go down
this way
and uh you cannot go out that would be
if that's the case this would be a
solution
but the point of this picture is to show
you that with three values
i can make you query everywhere without
understanding anything about the picture
that is that is what i wanted to convey
yeah uh so a question from young son
is there any issue like from poverty
will help the picture on the right
concavity from cavity
where does it help in the industry if it
was too big
oh uh
it's still hard
[Music]
what
the problem is gonna you unless you put
both convex of cavities not gonna help
you
oh oh you mean like if this come back to
cave
[Music]
uh you know like uh
um i mean i don't know but uh
uh
it's more like
[Music]
it's it's i mean
it's not i mean you still have to do an
analysis kind of like the one i did
yesterday to to you know to drive you
something but like
roughly speaking you know there is a
center point in the middle and you know
you come at it
if you you know make the right moves
with this negative momentum when there
is
you have to still have to like i cannot
wave my hands easily uh to convince you
because
ultimately yesterday i waved my hands
twice and then i showed the proof that
was
that took a while to show but uh yeah
what's this yeah it is maybe the case
that if it is commercial game that means
that you do not have enough freedom to
put
the next three to one the next
because of the structure oh you mean
like uh okay
this is a clear okay
so that is a partial answer to me like
suddenly like these values cannot appear
right because in this vertical line
similarly this okay so thank you so that
is a good idea for this picture but i
don't have a
necessarily good intuition about you
know
so i i think it's fairly easy to see
that uh
the worst case it would cycle and and
the average would be the settled one
right
like if you just
do gradient oh sure okay yeah i mean
like
any uh analysis of another learner or
already in descent that has average
converts and suffices for my purposes
because i'm looking at a computational
problem that's right
uh i don't need to elastic
that is correct
another question for the
ppid is it for the constraint case
it is for the constraint case we don't
know how to prove it for the
like like uh
like for the hardest result
negativities are gonna be okay smooth
uh the domain is uh
it's going to be
kind of this is going to have some
entanglement between the two players the
minimizer and the maximizer
it's not going to be a problem
so this could be some thought for the
gun people because
um
they don't put any constraints
and
yeah do i believe
do you believe that the atmosphere would
still be hard if you put like a lot of
strongly convinced penalties
that would mimic constraints uh
the unconstraint problem
uh
i would
let him say that with constraints with a
product of science i think it's still
hard
now
you have to tell me what exactly like
what
you wanted to have completely
constrained
don't you um ever project
uh
when you do gun training
let me i mean
my guess is still hard but uh
uh but uh you know again i think uh it
can yeah it is
through the product constraints possibly
also
you know like l2 panels and stuff
that's an interesting question for the
semester
okay uh okay so what i wanted to do is
to show you actually dive a bit deeper
the proof but let's do it later
[Applause]
this
the